stay-at-home Orders are now in place in
eight states and all Americans have been
warned against holding large gatherings
but now everybody is listening
California beaches were crowded over the
weekend
New York's Prospect Park was also busy
even though the state has more cases
than anywhere else in the country
Governor Cuomo made it clear that is not
okay our lead national correspondent
David Beck now is reporting four men
from his Manhattan home David we
understand the rules have gotten more
strict since yesterday Governor Cuomo
not happy he's not playing around Gail
listen you've heard a lot about New York
California and Washington and for good
reason this morning we're gonna tell you
about Louisiana two weeks ago the bayou
state had zero cases confirmed as of
this morning they are closing in on 900
we'll take you to Louisiana for that but
as Gail said we are going to begin in
New York where the governor has said all
non-essential gatherings no matter how
many people are involved in it no one
can gather together the always bustling
New York City is practically a ghost
town most businesses have closed and the
streets are nearly empty and there are
similar scenes around the country with
deserted tourist destinations in Atlanta
Georgia all the way to California's
Hollywood Walk of Fame
still the Governor of New York says he's
personally seen parks
crowded with people despite an order
that he gave to stay at home it's
insensitive its arrogant
its self-destructive it's disrespectful
to other people and it has to stop and
it has to stop now over the weekend in
California some people were still hiking
and sunbathing even though there's an
order there to stay at home to
California along with New York and
Washington State are starting to get
federal disaster funds for mass care and
other emergency programs some hospitals
have set up tents in the parking lot
just start triaging people before they
even walk in the door kovat 19 is
affecting people of all ages take forty
four-year-old David Lattin
he's a marathon runner and lawyer who
founded the widely read blog called
above the law he's now on a ventilator
at a New York City Hospital at first
doctors thought he might have the flu so
they sent him home it turned out to be
coronavirus his husband last spoke to
him three days ago as David was in the
ICU he didn't sound great you know we
couldn't really talk for more than two
seconds so I just said hi he said he
wasn't doing great said I love you he's
in isolation he is health professionals
in some states continue to be worried
about how the requests to get more
medical supplies and federal dollars are
getting prioritized take Louisiana for
example more than a million people
visited New Orleans last month for Mardi
Gras now Louisiana's governor says
according to a study from the University
of Louisiana at Lafayette that state has
the fastest growth rate of confirmed
cases anywhere in the world I want the
nation I know how important it is and
Louisiana needs help dr. Rebecca ghee
says Louisiana is set to become the
epicenter of this pandemic when you look
at cases per capita listen before I toss
back Anthony I want you to know that
private companies are volunteering to
help produce supplies and equipment
President Trump said yesterday that
Hanes and 3m are offering to make masks
Tesla and Ford have offered to produce
ventilators and Bacardi based in Puerto
Rico you
shifting some of its production to make
hand sanitiser alright David thanks